cada día estas mujeres se dirigen a este
barrio pobre del sur de nueva delhi
desafiando el calor visitan decenas de
viviendas
en la india es imposible hablar de salud
sin hablar de ellas se les conoce como
las trabajadoras ya hechas significa
esperanza en hindi son más de un millón
en el país
su papel velar cotidianamente por la
salud de los habitantes en los barrios
más pobres este barrio nos fue asignado
y le hacemos seguimiento a unas 400
casas eso representa 2000 habitantes y
cuidamos a cada uno de ellos hay mujeres
embarazadas o adultos mayores todos los
días hacemos como una investigación en
el vecindario ni médico ni enfermera
estas trabajadoras médicos sociales con
frecuencia son las primeras
interlocutoras de las comunidades
marginadas inc y las
este programa nació en el 2006
inicialmente le hacía frente a los
desiertos médicos en las zonas rurales
en especial para convencer a las futuras
madres para que tengan sus partos en el
hospital en mes de casa y disminuir así
la mortalidad infantil y materna y ello
apoyándose en una red de mujeres
provenientes de los pueblos donde acuden
a una serie de talleres de formación
entre los problemas recurrentes podemos
citar a las mujeres embarazadas que no
tienen acceso a atención frecuente para
su embarazo
o los recién nacidos que sufren de
fiebre o diarreas porque el primer
hospital está muy lejos de estas
familias la idea del programa 'las ágil
era entonces formar mujeres en atención
primaria y permitirles a estas
poblaciones integrarse al sistema de
salud ya que en la india rural hacen
falta doctores las zonas son rurales
cuentan con el 65% de la población pero
sólo con el 30 del personal médico del
país y con frecuencia en clínicas
privadas costosas para la mayoría de la
población
peor aún dos médicos de cada tres en la
india no contarían ni con los diplomas
en y con las competencias requeridas
ejercer una cifra en aumento fuera de
las zonas urbanas a 1500 kilómetros al
este de la capital india el estado de
orissa es uno de los más pobres del país
matilda cuyo es una trabajadora allá
desde hace 16 años fue una de las
primeras en la india quien ha cargo a
cerca de 1000 familias en un radio de 5
kilómetros un trabajo puerta a puerta
enorme debe velar que las personas
enfermas sigan correctamente su
tratamiento tal es el caso de este
hombre que tiene letra
muéstrame
el pie dejó de inflamar se me dijeron
que todos los medicamentos durante un
año si todos los días durante un año y
sobre todo tómese lo siempre es un
primer mes de tratamiento y ya va mejor
verificó que se tome los medicamentos
porque debe entender que si no lo hacen
no sanará
también debo recordarle que no debe
beber alcohol porque de lo contrario el
tratamiento no funcionará
educar cambiar los malos hábitos
matilda debió luchar cotidianamente los
prejuicios y las supersticiones locales
me di cuenta de que muchas personas
desconocen los beneficios del hospital
querían ser sanados en casa solamente
pero ahora todas las mujeres del pueblo
van a la clínica para los partos por
ejemplo antes numerosos pacientes
automedicaban con base en lo que se
decía eso también cambió van a ver a un
médico y compra en el buen tratamiento
el otro problema el que están
confrontadas las trabajadoras asia es la
relación con las castas siempre lo deben
tener en cuenta
algunas personas les dicen no te sientes
a mi lado si hacen parte de una casta
inferior a la suya
con el paso de los años a las misiones
confiadas a las trabajadoras de la
esperanza se multiplicaron planificación
familiar lucha contra el polio y la
tuberculosis campaña de vacunación más
recientemente estuvieron en primera
línea durante la pandemia vamos a
conducir un programa de vacunación a
domicilio por favor estén presentes
cuando debemos recibir nuestra tercera
dosis nueve meses después de la segunda
dosis pero ahora matilda hay decenas de
miles de trabajadoras sociales que están
luchando en otra frente desde hace
varios meses a lo largo del país
multiplican las huelgas y las
manifestaciones para exigir un ajuste de
calificación de su estatus porque para
el estado indio las trabajadoras ya son
voluntarias reciben una pequeña
indemnización y no hacen parte del
cuerpo médico según las regiones que
hagan entre 40 y 100 euros mensuales un
ingreso pequeño para quienes arriesgan
su vida para salvar la de otros
durante la pandemia nuestro trabajo se
ha reducido el gobierno dijo que
habíamos hecho un trabajo extra manera
que nos ofrecían flores como recompensa
pero no es suficiente usar todas estas
familias que lo han darme el salario
alguien queremos ser reconocidas como
verdaderas enfermeros queremos contar
con seguridad social hay una atención y
estamos sociales y cognitivos vean lo
que su entrega fue recompensada por la
ms que les otorgó el premio de los
líderes de la salud mundial un inicio de
reconocimiento para las que se volvieron
ángeles guardianes de decenas de
millones de desvalidos